MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
My name is Martin
Omander, and I welcome you
to Google Root Access, the show
featuring actionable startup
advice.
My guest today is
Nelson Pereira,
co-founder of the
start-up TOPdocs.
Thanks for coming
in today, Nelson.
And could you tell us a
bit about your start-up?
NELSON PEREIRA: First, thank
you for having me here, Martin.
TOPdocs is a cross-format
and cross-cloud-platform word
processor for mobile
and web, allowing people
from different clouds
to collaborate together
on Microsoft Office documents,
Open Office, and Google Docs.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So how come you got
started, or noticed
that this was a problem?
NELSON PEREIRA: Yeah.
It started three
years ago when I
was teaching UI and
UX design in college.
And I started my PhD in
digital media back then.
And I wanted to use
these all-new devices,
the tablet madness, to
work outside the office,
leaving the laptop
at home, finally.
But I start to face
all kinds of problems.
Compatibility of the
software wasn't there yet.
So after are a lot of research
and trying to find apps,
I decided to build my own tools.
And then I went to Miguel,
and I challenged with him
to join to the project.
He jumped in right away.
He liked it.
He liked the idea.
Well, yes.
Let's build this.
So we started researching
for technology,
how to fix a problem,
where to start.
And on that search, we
found [? Flochan ?],
which is the third team
member, which was also
working on this kind of problem.
So we team up together,
we start building,
and we are very proud of
what we achieve right now.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great, great.
So I think, Nelson, right
now, many of our viewers
are thinking, what are
these guys thinking,
going into such a crowded
market space, online document
collaboration?
We have the Microsofts,
and Googles, and Apples,
and Dropboxes of
the world already
in there building solutions.
How do you think about
entering such a market?
And where do you see your niche?
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
There is a lot of
good tools out there.
All these big players are
creating amazing products,
but all of them are
for their platforms.
And that's where
the big problem is.
And that's the problem
that we are trying to fix.
Because if you use your
Google Drive as a cloud space
to sync all your
files and devices,
and you're happy with it,
and then you go to mobile
and you start to try to edit
those with Microsoft Office,
and that's not possible, because
Office is locked to OneDrive.
And that's why we have a
niche and an opportunity
to work on this very
high-competition field of text
collaboration documents.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you're saying
your strategic opportunity is
then that these cloud providers
don't support each other very
well.
But you can be that layer
to support everybody.
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly, because
we are creating a solution that
will help people from
Dropbox or Google Drive
to collaborate together
on a Microsoft Office
document, which,
right now, is nearly
impossible in the mobile space.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Are there other strategic
opportunities like that,
features that you see
the big players are
lacking in or lagging in?
NELSON PEREIRA: Yes.
One of the most critical is
interoperability problems,
because all these
big players have
their own format
for collaboration.
And they are not
very likely to push
for supporting each
other's formats.
So when you try to edit on
mobile, example for Google
Docs, trying to edit a Microsoft
Office document on mobile,
you end up with a
very hard moment.
The document destroyed.
Loss of information,
footnotes, objects,
when you go back
to the computer.
So you need to trust your mobile
tool to perform those editings.
And that's the
other place where we
think there's an opportunity
and a problem to fix,
because the big players won't
try to push each other formats.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So what if Microsoft
or Google or Apple
comes out the next biggest
developer conference
and announces a new feature
that duplicates something
that you've built?
Isn't that a big risk?
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
We are very aware
of this situation,
because every summer,
every major tech company,
like Google I/O conferences,
they announce new features,
a bunch of start-ups just die.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
NELSON PEREIRA: Because they
are very tied to the ecosystem
and to a specific problem.
So what we're doing
is we are trying
to be as platform-agnostic
as possible,
trying to be independent,
and try to fix problems
that these big players
are not likely to fix
in the next coming times.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
So many start-ups
are, like you, working
within existing app ecosystems.
What advice would
you give to them?
NELSON PEREIRA: Well,
first, find your niche.
Find a specific problem
that those big players
won't fix for the coming times--
because they don't want it not,
because they don't have
the resources to do it,
because they have.
And also try to be as
independent as possible
from these platforms.
Try to find your business
and your way of working,
and not being tied to
just one app ecosystem.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so
span multiple systems.
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
As many cloud platforms and
mobile operating systems
as possible.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So that sounds great, in theory.
And I'm sure a lot of start-ups
would love to do that.
But isn't that awfully hard?
NELSON PEREIRA: Yes, it's hard.
And that's why we
started it, because it
was a great challenge, too.
But if you go to try
to fix the hardest
problems, but real problems
that people really have,
you'll end up in
a space that also
is less crowded, like
start-up competition.
And you may have higher
possibilities to succeed.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
I see.
Well, thank you very much
for sharing your experiences
with us today, Nelson.
NELSON PEREIRA: Thank you,
Martin, for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That's it for today.
I hope you found
something useful that you
can use in your start-up.
If you have comments
on the show,
please enter them in the
YouTube Comments section.
We love reading your comments.
We read everything you write.
Finally, if you're a
high-tech entrepreneur,
go to
developers.google.com/startups
to find out how
Google can help you.
That's it for today.
See you next time.